Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the evening of the 27th of June, 1787, the historian Edward Gibbon wrote the final sentences of his great book, The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire. It was, he wrote, among the ruins of the capital that I first conceived the idea of a work which has amused and exercised nearly 20 years of my life. And since then, he said, his research had taken in many of the events most interesting in human annals, from the artful policy of the Caesars to the foundations of Constantinople, from the character and religion of Muhammad to the ruin of the Greek Empire in the Middle Age. The fall of
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公元1787年6月27日傍晚，历史学家爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）写下了他的巨著《罗马帝国衰亡史》（The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire）的最后几句话。他写道，正是在首都的废墟之中，我第一次萌生了创作这部作品的想法，它消遣并消耗了我近二十年的生命。自那以后，他说，他的研究涉足了人类编年史上许多最有趣的事件，从恺撒诡谲的政策到君士坦丁堡的建立，从穆罕默德的性格与宗教到中世纪希腊帝国的覆灭。
Rome, said Gibbon, was the greatest, perhaps, and most awful scene in the history of mankind. But Tom Holland, it took Gibbon 20 years to write that book. It's a massive, massive book. And what he doesn't actually quite tell you is when the Roman Empire fell, because the story of the decline and fall for Gibbon takes centuries and it actually goes on for centuries after the date that is most commonly given as the fall of the Roman Empire so if I look it up on Wikipedia Tom or in Google it will give me the date 476 and I think this whole podcast is about when Rome fell. And we wouldn't be doing this podcast if 476 was the easy answer, would we? No, absolutely not. So I think that this is
吉本说，罗马的衰亡，或许是人类历史上最大、也最令人敬畏的场景。但是，汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），吉本花了20年才写完那本书。这是一本极其宏大的巨著。而他其实并没有确切告诉你罗马帝国是什么时候灭亡的，因为在吉本看来，衰亡的故事持续了几个世纪，而且实际上在通常被认定为罗马帝国灭亡的那个日期之后，它还延续了几个世纪。所以，如果我在维基百科或谷歌上查一下，汤姆，它给出的日期是476年，我觉得我们这整个播客讨论的就是罗马是什么时候灭亡的。如果我们能把476年当成那个简单的答案，我们就不会做这个播客了，对吧？不，绝对不是。所以我认为这是一个
a really interesting angle on the whole process of, well, as Gibbon said, the decline and fall of the Roman Empire. And is there a single date where you can say the Roman Empire fell? As you said, the kind of the traditional date, I mean, actually, you know, there's the 23rd of August 476, which is when the very last Roman Emperor is deposed. And he has the ironic name of Romulus Augustulusus and it's ironic because Romulus was the first king of Rome Augustus so Augustus means little Augustus was the first Roman emperor so it seems a kind of perfect drawing of the line under the great structure but of course as Gibbon suggested in that passage that you read there is the salient fact that of course what we're
非常有趣的切入点，切入了整个过程——正如吉本所说，罗马帝国的衰亡。那么，有没有哪一个确切的日期，能让你说罗马帝国就是在那一天灭亡的呢？正如你所说，那种传统的日期，实际上你知道，有公元476年8月23日，那是最后一任罗马皇帝被废黜的日子。他有个充满讽刺意味的名字叫罗慕路斯·奥古斯ゥ卢斯（Romulus Augustulus），之所以讽刺，是因为罗慕路斯是罗马的第一任国王，而奥古斯——奥古斯都的意思是“小奥古斯都”——奥古斯都则是第一位罗马皇帝。所以这似乎是在伟大建筑上画上句号的完美方式。但当然，正如吉本在你刚才朗读的那段话中所暗示的那样，有一个显而易见的事实，那就是我们所
talking about is the fall of the Roman empire in the West, and there is an eastern half ruled from Constantinople. And that, of course, continues until Constantinople falls to the Turks in 1453. And that has been the other traditional date on which the Roman Empire falls. Now, I would argue that both those dates are inadequate, although both of them are very, very significant punctuation points. So I thought that this would be a kind of interesting way to explore the broader theme of decline and fall. It's a brilliant way of doing it, actually. It's a much more interesting way in some ways than why did it decline and fall fall but maybe we should start with the empire itself i mean obviously this is a whole different podcast but when did the roman empire start imperium which we translate as as empire means kind of
讨论的是西罗马帝国的灭亡，还有一个由君士坦丁堡统治的东方半壁江山。而那个东方帝国，当然一直持续到君士坦丁堡在1453年被土耳其人攻陷。那一直是罗马帝国灭亡的另一个传统日期。现在，我认为这两个日期都不够充分，尽管它们都是非常、非常重要的标点符号。所以我认为，这会是一个探索“衰亡”这一更广阔主题的有趣方式。这确实是个绝妙的方法。从某些方面来看，它比单纯探讨“为什么它会衰亡”要有趣得多，但也许我们应该从帝国本身开始。我的意思是，这显然是一个完全不同的宏大话题，但罗马帝国究竟是什么时候开始的？“Imperium”这个词，我们将其翻译为“帝国”，意味着统治
rule authority and it's something that is invested to begin with with magistrates, with political figures. And it's only once that comes to be associated with physical territory that you start to get the idea of an imperium being something physical, so being an empire. And I suppose, you know, if you're saying on that level, Rome, according to legend, is founded as an aggressively military state so romulus the first king um he he launches an attack on a neighboring king kills him with his own hand brings his armor back dedicates it to um the to jupiter on the on the capitol um below which gibbon many many centuries later would meditate on the fall of the empire. But he dedicates the armor. He celebrates a great triumph.
权力，它最初是赋予给地方长官和政治人物的。只有当它开始与实体领土联系在一起时，你才会开始产生“Imperium”是一种实体、也就是一个帝国的概念。我想，如果你从这个层面来讲，根据传说，罗马建立之初就是一个极具侵略性的军事国家。所以第一任国王罗慕路斯，他发起了对邻国国王的进攻，亲手杀死了对方，把他的盔甲带了回来，并将其献给——献给卡比托利欧山上的朱庇特——多年以后，吉本正是在这座山下沉思帝国的衰亡。但他献上了盔甲，举行了盛大的凯旋仪式。
And from that point on, Rome is a military power. And it's a military power of a kind that the Mediterranean had never seen before. And the measure of that is that Rome ends up achieving something that no power in history has ever done, which is to bring the entire seaboard of the Mediterranean under its unitary control. So that happens under, I mean, at that point where you've got the whole of the Mediterranean, that basically happens under Augustus. And the first century BC, under Octavian,
从那一刻起，罗马就成了一个军事强国。而且是一个地中海从未见过的军事强国。衡量这一点标准是，罗马最终取得了历史上任何力量都未曾完成的壮举——将整个地中海沿岸置于其单一统治之下。这发生在一个——我的意思是，当你拥有整个地中海的时候，这基本上发生在奥古斯都统治时期。公元前1世纪，在屋大维统治下，
Julius Caesar's adopted heir, who takes the title Augustus or was given him by the Senate. And he's commonly remembered as the first emperor. I mean, his name was Imperator. He changed his name, didn't he? Yes. I mean, all these names. So Augustus means halfway to heaven, basically. So you're halfway to heaven, victorious general, son of a god. These are all proper names. They're not titles. So he's in many ways a sensationally immodest man. And what you say, what you could say.
也就是尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar）的养子，他接受了“奥古斯都”这个称号，或者说这是元老院赐予他的。人们通常记住他是第一位皇帝。我的意思是，他的名字叫“Imperator”（统帅）。他改过名字，对吧？是的。我的意思是，所有这些名字。所以“奥古斯都”基本上意味着“半步天堂”。所以你既是半步天堂之人、常胜将军，又是神的儿子。这些都是专有名词，而不是头衔。所以在很多方面，他是一个极其厚颜无耻的人。你可以这么说……
So if you're looking for dates for the fall of Rome, the end of Rome, what you could say is that Rome ends when the Roman people become slaves. So when the res publica, the affairs of the public matters of the state are subordinated to the rule of one man rather than to the Senate and the people of Rome. And so that is a view that accompanies the civil wars that leads to the rise to power of Augustus. So the emblematic figure who symbolizes that is a man called Cato.
因此，如果你在寻找罗马灭亡、罗马终结的日期，你可能会说，当罗马人民变成奴隶时，罗马就终结了。也就是说，当“共和国”（res publica）、公共事务和国家大权从元老院和罗马人民手中，屈从于一个人的统治时。因此，这种观点伴随着导致奥古斯都崛起的一系列内战。因此，象征这一现象的标志性人物是一个名叫加图（Cato）的人。
Yeah. Cato the Younger. There's an elder one who's also famous. And when we did our episode on the crossing of the Rubicon and the kind of the backstory of that, the collapse of the Republic, Cato was, we left Cato out because he was in a way a too bigger figure to introduce. But he's a figure who, for his contemporaries, symbolized everything that made the Republic Roman. So he was a kind of steely, flinty embodiment of the determination of the Romans never to accept rule by a single man and the sense that to be Roman was to reject slavery.
是的，小加图（Cato the Younger）。还有一个也很有名的老加图。当我们做关于跨越卢比孔河以及共和国崩溃背景的单口节目时，我们把加图漏掉了，因为从某种程度上说，他是一个过于宏大而无法引入的人物。但他对同时代的人来说，象征着让罗马共和国成为“罗马”的一切。因此，他是罗马人绝不接受一人统治的坚定决心的化身，代表着一种信念：身为罗马人就意味着拒绝奴隶制。
And Caesar crosses the Rubicon. He wins a sequence of great victories. One of these is fought at a battle in North Africa at a place called Thapsus in 46 BC. And Cato is in a town called Utica. He's brought the news of this great defeat that Caesar's army is marching towards Utica. And he kills himself. And this provides a model of behavior that aristocrats who look back to the great days of the Republic, when aristocrats like them had not been subordinated to Caesars, would every so often kind of take up
接着恺撒跨越了卢比孔河，赢得了一连串伟大的胜利。其中一场战役于公元前46年在北非塔普苏斯（Thapsus）打响。加图当时在一个叫乌蒂卡（Utica）的小镇里。他得到了这场惨败的消息，得知恺撒的军队正向乌蒂卡逼近。于是他自杀了。这为后来的贵族提供了一种行为模式：每当这些贵族回顾共和国的辉煌岁月——那时像他们这样的贵族还没有沦为恺撒们的臣属时——他们就会时不时地将此作为
as a model. So under the oppression of particularly tyrannical Caesars, they would commit suicide and consciously evoke the model of Cato. And the reason for that is it was kind of summed up by Cicero, the great orator who himself ends up being put to death by the alliance between Mark Antony and the future Augustus. And he wrote that every other people, every other nation, every other city, they can endure slavery. And the evidence of that is that they have submitted to Roman rule, but Rome cannot. And so therefore, if Rome submits to slavery, it is no longer Rome. Well, that's obviously, yeah. I mean the fact that rome does then persist with under the emperor's centuries suggests that i mean if cicero pitched up in the fourth century or third century and said this is not rome i mean people just laughed at him yeah but you can see the rhetorical force of it yeah because the moral force of it yeah because that's him rome is an
效仿的榜样。因此，在饱受尤其暴虐的恺撒们的压迫时，他们会选择自杀，并有意识地唤起加图的形象。之所以如此，正如伟大的演说家西塞罗（Cicero）所总结的那样——西塞罗本人最终也死于马克·安东尼与未来的奥古斯都的联盟之手。他写道，其他所有人、其他所有民族、其他所有城市，都能忍受奴隶制。证明这一点的就是他们已经向罗马统治屈服了，但罗马不能。因此，如果罗马屈服于奴隶制，它就不再是罗马了。嗯，这显然是……对，我的意思是，罗马在皇帝统治下又延续了几个世纪这一事实表明——如果西塞罗在公元4世纪或3世纪突然出现并说“这不是罗马”，人们只会嘲笑他。是的，但你能看出其中的修辞力量。是的，因为它的道德力量。是的，因为对西塞罗而言，罗马是一个
idea but obviously for the for the rome is an idea that's a republican idea, but obviously for the duration of what we commonly think of as the empire, so the period from Augustus onwards, Rome doesn't mean freedom from slavery so much as it means order, structure, continuity, law,
概念。但显然，对于我们通常所理解的帝国存续期间——也就是从奥古斯都开始的时期——罗马不再意味着摆脱奴隶制的自由，而是更多地意味着秩序、结构、连续性、法律、
taxation, security, these kinds of things that are commonly attributed by empires to themselves. And there is a kind of, I mean, that's, I mean, there is obviously a continuity of a time period where power is exercised over the Mediterranean, the surrounding territories, largely from central Italy. And obviously then it moves away. But we we can talk about so the empire in the fourth century let's say I mean it looks different in lots of ways but it's still the same civilization isn't it as yes as the the empire in the first century BC created by Augustus so a century before
税收、安全，这些通常是帝国赋予自身的属性。而且某种程度上，我的意思是，这显然存在一个时间上的连续性：权力在很大程度上从意大利中部对地中海及周边领土实行统治。当然，后来权力中心转移了。但我们可以讨论——比如公元4世纪的帝国，我的意思是，它在很多方面看起来都不同了，但它仍然是同一个文明，对吧？就像奥古斯都在公元前1世纪——即一个世纪前——创建的帝国一样。
in 248 Rome had celebrated its millennium and this is in the middle of the third century, which is a period of convulsive civil war, barbarian invasions, general collapse. And yet there is in this celebration of the millennium, a sense that already that Rome is becoming the eternal city. And so the idea that Rome cannot fall is really starting to bed down and actually I mean this is this is quite a radical kind of change because actually for for most of their history the Romans had been shadowed by a sense that Rome might fall I mean there's that you know it there's absolutely a sense in the Mediterranean that is conquered by Rome that empires rise and empires fall because they've seen what happened to Egypt, what happened to Alexander the Great's empire,
公元248年，罗马庆祝了它的建城千年。这正值公元3世纪中期，这是一个伴随着混乱的内战、蛮族入侵和全面崩溃的时期。然而，在千禧年的庆祝活动中，人们有一种感觉：罗马正在成为永恒之城。因此，“罗马永不沦陷”的观念真正开始扎根。实际上，这是一种相当激进的转变，因为在罗马历史的大部分时间里，罗马人都被一种“罗马可能会灭亡”的阴影所笼罩。我的意思是，在被罗马征服的地中海地区，绝对存在这样一种观念：帝国有兴也有衰，因为他们目睹了埃及的遭遇、亚历山大大帝帝国的遭遇，
or the Seleucids, or all those kinds of empires, right? Well, the classic example is when the first great kind of imperial rival that Rome fights and then brings to destruction is Carthage. So there are three terrible wars, and the third war against Carthage culminates when the Romans lay siege to Carthage. They capture it and they destroy it utterly. You know, they wipe out not just the physical fabric of the city, but they burn its libraries.
或是塞琉古帝国，以及所有这类帝国的命运，对吧？经典的例子就是，罗马与之战斗并最终将其消灭的第一个伟大帝国死敌是迦太基。双方爆发了三次残酷的战争，第三次对迦太基的战争以罗马人围攻迦太基达到高潮。他们攻占了这座城市并将其彻底摧毁。你知道，他们不仅抹去了城市的物理结构，还烧毁了它的图书馆。
So that in a sense, their aim is to render the very memory of Carthage absolutely gone. But Scipio Aemilianus, who's the general who has captured Carthage, he's watching it and he starts to weep. And he quotes lines from Homer describing the ruin of Troy that will come. And he turns to a companion of his who's a Greek Polybius historian who himself has been brought as a kind of hostage from Greece by the Romans. And he says, you know, I dread that the fate that we are now visiting on Carthage will be visited on Rome as well. And he is, I mean, he's not unusual in saying that. Lots of Romans worry about that. And it's absolutely part of the kind of cultural swirl of the second and first centuries BC. But also, isn't that the kind of thing that you say when your hegemony is more fragile?
从某种意义上说，他们的目的是让人们对迦太基的记忆彻底消失。但是，攻陷迦太基的将军小西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）在目睹这一切时，却流下了眼泪。他引用了荷马史诗中描述特洛伊废墟即将到来的诗句。他转向身边的一位同伴——希腊历史学家波利比乌斯（Polybius），后者本人作为人质被罗马人从希腊带到这里。他对波利比乌斯说，你知道的，我担心我们现在施加在迦太基身上的命运，将来也会降临到罗马头上。他的这种担忧并非特例。许多罗马人都为此感到焦虑。这绝对是公元前2和1世纪文化思潮的一部分。不过，难道这不正是当你的霸权更加脆弱时才会说的话吗？
So when you're competing with people, when you know that you might lose. I mean, do people say that under Hadrian, under Trajan, centuries later when Rome appears? No, I think you're absolutely right that it is bred of the sense of instability. So the same year that Carthage is burned, the Romans also destroy Corinth, which is one of the great cities of Greece. And that generates an amazing sense of instability across the Mediterranean that these two famous cities can be wiped out. And you have, you know, so the Greeks absolutely have a sense that empires rise and fall. So Herodotus, the very first historian in the opening of his book, he says that, you know, powers that were great are now
所以，当你与他人竞争、当你深知自己可能会失败时。我的意思是，在几个世纪后罗马如日中天的时候，哈德良和图拉扬统治时期，人们还会这么说吗？不，我认为你说得对，这确实源于一种不稳定性。迦太基被焚毁的同一年，罗马人还摧毁了希腊的伟大城市之一科林斯（Corinth）。这在整个地中海引发了一种惊人的不稳定感，人们意识到这两座著名的城市竟然可以被彻底抹去。于是，希腊人绝对产生了一种“帝国有盛必衰”的观念。因此，希腊第一位历史学家希罗多德（Herodotus）在其著作的开篇就说过，曾经强大的力量如今变得
small and vice versa. And this is one of the reasons that he wants to write his history. So he feels that he's recording the rise and fall of empires. And of course, you've got the Jews as well with that. You know, we've talked about the book of Daniel in, I think, in the Babylon episode, didn't we? Where he sees four beasts coming out of the ocean. And he's told that these beasts are empires that will succeed one after the other.
弱小，反之亦然。这也是他想要撰写历史的原因之一。他觉得自己正在记录帝国的兴衰。当然，犹太人也有这种观念。你知道的，我们在巴比伦那一集中讨论过《但以理书》（Book of Daniel），对吧？他在书中看到四只巨兽从海中浮现。有人告诉他，这些兽就是将相继崛起的帝国。
So, and these Greek and Jewish traditions kind of merge and blur to create prophecies that are attributed to old women called Sybils. And these in the first and second centuries B.C. are predicting that Rome will fall. And of course, the Romans themselves are aware of this. You know, they don't want to think about it. But when the civil wars happen, when Caesar crosses the Rubicon, when you have the civil wars between Antony Cleopatra and the future Augustus. People in Rome look at these prophecies and worry about it. And they have kind of terrible fantasies of Rome being trampled down by enemy horsemen, of the capital being burned.
因此，这些希腊和犹太传统相互融合、交织，创造出了归属于被称为“西比尔”（Sybil）的古代女预言家的预言。在公元前1和2世纪，这些预言都在预测罗马将会灭亡。当然，罗马人自己也意识到了这一点。他们虽然不愿去想它，但当内战爆发、当恺撒跨越卢比孔河、当安东尼与克莉奥帕特拉同未来的奥古斯都爆发内战时，罗马的人们就会审视这些预言并为此感到担忧。他们脑海中浮现出可怕的幻想：罗马被敌人的骑兵践踏，首都化为火海。
So Horace, the great great poet writes about this but then the achievement of augustus really is to reassure the cultural elites in rome and indeed i think more beyond the cultural elites of the mass of the people that civil war is something that is is no longer going to happen therefore that rome is stable and therefore people can start looking to the future so horace ends up writing. He says, you know, he hopes that his poetry will be eternal. And he compares the eternity he wants for his poetry with the spectacle of the pontiff climbing up the Capitol to offer sacrifice to Jupiter. And he envisages that this will happen forever and ever and ever. And this, although you do have a renewed bound of civil war in AD 69, and although you do then have civil wars starting to corrode the fabric of the empire in the third century, when Romans celebrate their millennium, they pretty much take for granted that Rome is eternal, that it does embody a kind of eternal ideal of how the world should be organized, that the gods will uphold, and there's no reason for it ever to fade.
因此，伟大的诗人贺拉斯（Horace）写下了这方面的诗篇。但奥古斯都真正的成就在于，他向罗马的文化精英——乃至文化精英之外的广大民众——保证，内战将不再发生，因此罗马是稳定的，人们可以开始展望未来。于是，贺拉斯在诗作的结尾写道。他说，他希望自己的诗歌能够永存。他将自己希望诗歌享有的永恒，与大祭司登上卡比托利欧山向朱庇特献祭的壮观景象相提并论。他设想这一幕将永远、永远、永远地发生下去。尽管在公元69年你们经历了一场新的内战，尽管在3世纪内战开始侵蚀帝国的肌体，但当罗马人庆祝建城千年时，他们基本上把“罗马是永恒的”、“罗马体现了世界应有组织方式的某种永恒理想”、“神明将永远维护它”视为理所当然，并且觉得没有任何理由让它黯然失色。
So let's take this story and let's go through the narrative a little bit. So Augustus sets up the empire at the sort of turn of the millennium, basically. I mean, that's the classic, I know it's obviously much more complicated, but that's the sort of classic textbook view. And then you have his successors, Julio-Claudians, and then you have a that's the sort of classic textbook view. And then you have his successors, the Julio-Claudians, and then you have a succession of kind of dynasties. And then you have this thing, I mean, so Zachary Watts,
让我们延续这个故事，稍微梳理一下历史脉络。奥古斯都在公元纪年之交左右建立了帝国。我的意思是，这是经典的——我知道这显然要复杂得多，但这是典型的教科书观点。然后是他的继承者克劳狄王朝，再然后是一连串的——这是典型的教科书观点。接着是他的继承者朱里安-克劳狄王朝，再然后是一系列不同的王朝。然后就出现了这样一件事——扎卡里·沃茨（Zachary Watts），
one of our listeners has asked us about the crisis of the third century. Is that a break, Tom? Because you start moving towards military emperors who are no longer from the old kind of, the ruling families, the patrician kind of families that dominated roman politics you get these officers who come and go kind of sometimes within a year right and and the at that point does the the system start to feel a bit
我们的听众之一向我们询问了关于三世纪危机的问题。汤姆，这是一个转折点吗？因为你开始转向那些不再出身于古老阶层、不再出身于主导罗马政治的贵族家族的军事皇帝。你会看到这些军官来来去去，有时甚至一年内就换人，对吧？那么在那个时候，这个系统开始让人感觉
different from what had been before or Or is there still an underlying continuity? Yeah, I think that the empire is transformed pretty radically in the third century, and has to be because otherwise it would disintegrate. And I think that the salient fact to remember when looking at both the making of the empire and its disintegration is just how vast the distances are, because this is a pre-industrial society. And the thing is that across the empire, there are obvious fracture points. So the Channel would be one, the Alps would be another, the Pyrenees would be another, the mountainous terrain of the Balkans separating Italy from the East would be another. And of course, the Mediterranean.
与以前有些不同了吗？还是说其中仍然存在着某种底层的连续性？是的，我认为帝国在3世纪发生了相当激进的转变，而且必须转变，否则它就会解体。我认为，在审视帝国的建立及其解体时，需要铭记的一个显着事实是，这里的距离是多么的辽阔，因为这是一个前工业化社会。问题在于，在整个帝国范围内，存在着明显的断裂带。英吉利海峡算一个，阿尔卑斯山算另一个，比利牛斯山脉算另一个，将意大利与东方隔开的巴尔干多山地形算另一个。当然，还有地中海。
And the Mediterranean serves to join the empire. You know, it's Mare Nostrum, it's our sea, the Romans call it. But it also divides. You know, it is, I think, telling that Rome is the only unitary power, the only power to have made the Mediterranean kind of, you know, its own territory, because it suggests that it is hard to join lands gathered around the Mediterranean kind of, you know, its own territory, because it suggests that it is hard
地中海起到了连接帝国的作用。它是“我们的海”（Mare Nostrum），罗马人是这么叫它的。但它也带来了分裂。我认为，地中海是唯一的单一政权、唯一一个将地中海变成“自己领土”的力量，这一事实本身就很说明问题，因为这表明，要把地中海周围汇聚的土地统一起来是多么困难。
to join lands gathered around the Mediterranean. And essentially, whenever you look at the civil wars that periodically break out in the empire, what you see are the same fracture points. So most obviously between the Greek speaking and the Latin speaking halves of the empire. But those are not just cultural. They're not just linguistic. They also correspond to the Adriatic is a really long line of sea that then joins with the rest of the Mediterranean. So it's a very, very obvious physical barrier. But then also you have, as I say, the Alps. So there are endless Gallic empires. Britain is always kind of drifting off.
基本上，每当你看到帝国定期爆发的内战时，你看到的都是同样的断裂带。最明显的就是讲希腊语的半壁江山和讲拉丁语的半壁江山之间。但这些不仅仅是文化上的，它们也不仅仅是语言上的。它们还对应着亚得里亚海——这是一条非常漫长的海域，然后与地中海的其他部分相连。所以这是一个非常、非常明显的天然屏障。但正如我所说，你还有阿尔卑斯山。所以有无数个高卢帝国。不列颠也总是处于分崩离析的边缘。
And basically, that is what the third century with its great crisis kind of exposes, is that it's quite easy for bits of the empire to drift off. And the only way that a central power can keep these together is by raising more taxes and spending them on the military. And to do that, essentially, you have to have a military person. And by this point, the central kind of belt of the Roman Empire has been demilitarized. And so increasingly, it's impossible to rule the Roman Empire from Rome, you have to do it from the frontiers. And so you get all these kind of burly, balkan, peasant figures who rise to become emperors. And of course you get Constantinople.
基本上，3世纪及其大危机所暴露出来的正是这一点：帝国的某些部分分崩离析是相当容易的。而中央政权能将这些部分维系在一起的唯一方法，就是征收更多税收并将其花在军队上。要做到这一点，你本质上必须有一个具有军事背景的人。而到了这个时候，罗马帝国的核心地带已经去军事化了。因此，越来越不可能从罗马来统治罗马帝国，你必须从边境地区来统治。于是你得到了所有这些粗犷的、巴尔干出身的农民式人物，他们崛起成为了皇帝。当然，你还有君士坦丁堡。
Constantinople gets founded because it is at a convenient distance between the two key fronts for Rome, which is the Danube-Rhin frontier, where there are Germanic tribes constantly kind of pressing against it. And the Eastern Front, where a very, very aggressive and powerful Persian empire has emerged, and again, is constantly kind of pressing against it. And Rome is wholly unsuited to provide a seat of empire from which to tend to both these two fronts. So that raises one of our first possible dates, which is 330.
君士坦丁堡的建立是因为它处于罗马两个关键战线之间的便利距离上。一个是对抗日耳曼部族的日耳曼-莱茵边线，日耳曼部族不断向其施压；另一个是东部战线，那里出现了一个非常、非常激进且强大的波斯帝国，同样不断向其施压。而罗马完全不适合作为一个帝国的都城来兼顾这两条战线。这就引出了我们可能的第一个日期，即公元330年。
So that's the foundation of Constantinople as a capital, as a rival capital. But there's no sense to people, you think at the time time that that marks a sort of definitive, you know, what we would call a full stop. It's a semicolon rather than a full stop, right? It's not the end of something. It's merely an evolution. Rome remains the kind of the emotional, the symbolic capital. I think that there is a certain degree of trauma at the kind of the bleeding of some of that kind of sacral, dare I say, emotional, cultural capital into Constantinople. But
这就是君士坦丁堡作为首都、作为 rival首都的建立。但当时的人们并不觉得这标志着某种决定性的——用我们的话说——句号。与其说是句号，不如说是分号，对吧？它不是某事物的终结，而仅仅是一种演变。罗马依然是那种情感上的、象征性的首都。我认为，那种神圣的、敢说带点情感和文化的资本，有一部分“流血”渗入到了君士坦丁堡，这在某种程度上确实带来了创伤。但
it's quite a gradual process. And so people within Rome are able to adjust to it, I think, fairly easily. And they don't feel, I think, that the empire is no longer Roman, because Constantinople is also, you know, it's the new Rome, it's the second Rome, and it's modelled on Rome. There is a, you know, a senate, the fabric of the city is modelled on the fabric of Rome itself. It said that the Palladium, which had been supposedly taken by Aeneas during the sack of Troy, and which had been the totem for Troy, had then gone to Rome and then had been taken by Constantine and taken to Constantinople. So there is perhaps that slight sense that there's been a migration. But I don't think in any way it leads anyone in the in the empire to think that the roman empire is no longer roman i mean it isn't and of course as you know the uh the the
这是一个相当渐进的过程。因此，罗马城内的人们能够相当轻松地适应它。我认为他们并不觉得帝国不再是罗马了，因为君士坦丁堡也是——你知道的，它是新罗马，是第二罗马，而且它是以罗马为蓝本建造的。这里有一个元老院，城市的建筑格局也是以罗马本身的格局为蓝本的。据说帕拉丁（Palladium）——据传说是在特洛伊沦陷期间被埃涅阿斯带走、并曾作为特洛伊图腾的圣物——后来被带到了罗马，然后又被君士坦丁带到了君士坦丁堡。所以，也许有一种轻微的“迁徙”感。但我认为这绝不会让帝国中的任何人觉得罗马帝国不再是罗马了——我的意思是，它本来就是。而且正如你所知，呃——我们今天通常称之为拜占庭的那个
empire that we today generally call byzantine they called themselves romans they were the romeo yeah well we'll come on to that in a second tom because i wanted to ask you about something else that is definitely associated with constantinople because in the in the public imagination i would say when people think about the empire that was based at constantinople the emperors at constantinople the images that we see in our minds are often they look very like icons i mean they're christian images and obviously is it 380 the edict of thessalonica um where theodosius the great makes christianity the state religion of Thessalonica, where Theodosius the Great makes Christianity the state religion of the Roman Empire. Now that to me as an outsider, as a historian of the very modern period,
帝国，他们自己称自己为罗马人。他们是罗马人（Romaioy）。好，我们一会儿再来谈这个，汤姆，因为我想问你关于另一件绝对与君士坦丁堡相关的事。因为在公众想象中，我想当人们想到以君士坦丁堡为中心的帝国、君士坦丁堡的皇帝时，我们脑海中浮现的影像往往看起来非常像圣像画——它们是基督教的图像。那么，是不是在公元380年的《萨洛尼卡敕令》（Edict of Thessalonica）中，大狄奥多西（Theodosius the Great）将基督教确立为萨洛尼卡——将基督教确立为罗马帝国的国教？作为一个局外人、一个近现代史学家，在我看来，
that to me looks like a definite punctuation point, a cultural revolution. I mean, is that too strong? It is a cultural revolution. You know, I think that Christianity is properly transformative. However, again, I don't think that that is how it seems to most Romans. For the same reason that, you know, a frog in a slowly heating saucepan doesn't realize that he's being cooked. Because Christianity gets legalized by Constantine because he has his vision of the cross in the sky. Jesus tells him, yes, conquer in this sign, the sign of the cross. And because we know what will happen and because we can recognize Christianity as something radically different to what had gone before, we attempted to see that as a kind of great fracture point, as with Theodosius as well. But basically, what Constantine is doing is what emperors have been doing actually for quite a long time, which is to audition a single, all-powerful god who can kind of serve as a mirror image for the emperor's rule on earth so you are an autocrat on earth ideally you want a single god who can provide a mirror image to you
这绝对是一个清晰的标点符号，一场文化革命。我的确觉得这个说法有点太强烈了吗？这确实是一场文化革命。你知道，我认为基督教确实具有变革性。然而，再次说明，我认为大多数罗马人不这么看。原因很简单：正如温水煮青蛙一样，锅里的青蛙并没有意识到自己正在被烹煮。基督教之所以被君士坦丁合法化，是因为君士坦丁在天空中看到了十字架的异象。耶稣告诉他：“是的，凭此标志征服，即十字架的标志。”正因为我们知道将会发生什么，且能将基督教视为与以往截然不同的事物，我们才倾向于把它看作一个巨大的断裂点，对狄奥多西也是如此。但基本上，君士坦丁所做的事，正是皇帝们实际上已经做了相当长一段时间的事——那就是挑选一个单一的、全能的神，让其成为皇帝在人间统治的镜像。所以在人间你是一个独裁者，理想情况下你需要一个单一的神来为你提供一个镜像。
and also because by you know by the third by the fourth century the idea is basically everyone is roman within the empire the old kind of of divisions between Romans and conquered peoples has faded. Every male, free male within the limits of the empire has become a citizen. And so therefore you, again, that's why you're kind of looking around for a single God who can provide a focus of loyalty for people in Egypt and Italy and Gaul and whatever. To sort of transcend the local gods. So Constantine, before he becomes a christian has been auditioning um hercules apollo sol invictus the the unconquered son so in that sense jesus is just the guy who passes the audition i mean he's not it doesn't seem that
而且，因为到3世纪、4世纪时，帝国的理念基本上是每个人都是罗马人，罗马人与被征服人民之间的旧有分歧已经消逝。帝国境内的每一个自由男性都成为了公民。因此，你再次四处寻找一个单一的神，以为埃及、意大利、高卢等各地的人们提供一个忠诚的焦点，从而超越地方神明。所以，在君士坦丁成为基督徒之前，他曾物色过赫拉克勒斯、阿波罗、无敌太阳神（Sol Invictus）。从这个意义上说，耶稣只是那个通过面试的人。我的意思是，这看起来并没有那么
radically different yeah of course over the course of of the the fourth century it comes you know people do start to wake up to the fact that actually something quite different is happening so you do get um towards the end of the fourth century you you have uh senators in rome who get terribly upset when um you know for instance statues within the senate house emblems within the senate house that they see as having kind of represented um you know, the symbols of Roman victory and so on. I mean, it's a bit like conservatives worrying about statues of Churchill being toppled or something like that. It has that kind of emotional impact, people that get upset about it. But again, I think even then, they're
激进的不同。当然，在4世纪的进程中，人们确实开始意识到，实际上正在发生一些非常不同的事情。所以你会发现，到了4世纪末，罗马的元老院议员们变得非常沮丧——当他们看到，例如元老院议事堂内的雕像、元老院议事堂内的徽标被视为代表了罗马胜利的象征等等时。我的意思是，这有点像保守派担心丘吉尔的雕像被推倒之类的事情。它具有那种情感冲击力，人们会为此感到沮丧。但再次说明，即使在那个时候，他们
not thinking that Rome itself has fallen, that rome itself has changed okay but i agree christianity is is is transformative let's deal with one more event in the fourth century before we take a break um the theodosius who's the emperor who makes christianity the state religion he dies in 395 i think it is um you're the expert not me he and he i think i'm right in saying, is the last emperor who rules the whole thing. Because on his death, am I right in thinking he divides it between Arcadius and Honorius, his two sons, eastern half, western half? Now, that's been done before. Diocletian has experimented with having four emperors working together, a sort of committee. But this is the point, after this point, after 395, there is never one man running the empire
也没有认为罗马本身已经灭亡，罗马本身已经改变。好吧，但我同意，基督教确实具有变革性。在我们休息之前，让我们再处理4世纪的另一个事件。大狄奥多西——那位将基督教定为国教的皇帝——死于公元395年，如果我没记错的话。你是专家，不是我。他——如果我没记错的话，他是最后一位统治整个帝国的皇帝。因为在他死后，我没记错的话，他把帝国分给了他的两个儿子阿尔卡迪乌斯（Arcadius）和霍诺留（Honorius），分为东半部和西半部？这以前也有人做过。戴克里先曾尝试过多位皇帝共同执政的委员会制。但从这一点开始，在395年之后，再也没有一个人独自统治整个帝国了。
ever again. Isn't that a big punctuation point, Tom? Yes, absolutely. It is. Although, as you say, it's not radically innovative. Because actually, I mean you go you go back to the first century bc and you think about those civil wars what's striking is how you get exactly the same split then so when caesar crosses the rubicon caesar takes possession of the western half including italy and pompey and the senate go to the eastern half and then of course octavia absolutely and that is formally done so there's there's you know there's a tramumvirate, but one of them, Lepidus, gets kind of shunted to one side. And essentially, you know, it is formally decre going against the grain of roman history for that to happen and you're right that that but from that point on the sense of there being a western half and an eastern half absolutely beds down and for those people who don't know who aren't experts in this uh the eastern half is the richer kind of more dynamic
难道这不是一个重大的标点符号吗，汤姆？是的，绝对是的。虽然如你所说，这并不是什么激进的创新。因为实际上，如果你回溯到公元前1世纪并思考那些内战，你会发现惊人的一点是当时也出现了完全相同的分裂。当恺撒跨越卢比孔河时，恺撒占领了包括意大利在内的西部，而庞培和元老院则去了东部。当然，屋大维也是如此。而且这是正式进行的，当时有过一个后三头同盟，但其中一人勒必达（Lepidus）被排挤到了一边。从本质上讲，正式颁布法令……这其实是违背罗马历史潮流的。你说得对，但从那一点开始，东西两半的意识彻底扎根了。对于那些不知道、不是这方面专家的人来说，
cosmopolitan it's basically the more interesting half even though we think of it the other way around isn't that right tom i mean yes so so absolutely the the uh the eastern half is compared to the western half fabulously rich that's not to say the western half doesn't have very rich areas as well it does but but the east is is more kind of cultured more sophisticated and and definitely has more gold. Okay, very good. We will take a break to inspect our own hordes of gold, and we will return to talk about more dates when the Roman Empire might have fallen or not.
东半部更富裕、更有活力、更具大都会气息，它基本上是有趣得多的半壁江山，尽管我们通常反过来想，难道不是这样吗，汤姆？我的意思是，是的。所以，东半部与西半部相比，极其富有。这并不是说西半部没有非常富裕的地区，它确实有，但东方更加文化昌明、更加精致，而且绝对拥有更多的黄金。好吧，非常好。我们将休息一下，去检视我们自己的黄金宝库，然后回来讨论罗马帝国可能已经灭亡——或者没有灭亡——的更多日期。
See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to
一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在问答环节中，我们还会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买
live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Tom, I bring tremendous news. Our friends at UnHerd have been back in touch. The free-thinking internet magazine. The crucial question, Tom, do you know how to spell it? U-N-H-E-R-D. I'm thrilled to have them back as sponsors because I think they've been going from strength to strength. Pushing back against herd mentality.
现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。汤姆，我带来了惊人的好消息。我们的朋友UnHerd又跟我们联系了。这家崇尚自由思考的网络杂志。最关键的问题，汤姆，你知道怎么拼写它吗？U-N-H-E-R-D。我很高兴他们作为赞助商回归，因为我认为他们的实力越来越强。坚决抵制群体思维。
Pushing back against herd mentality, but also recruiting really excellent columnists, among them yourself. Yes, I write for Unheard about every two weeks. I've written for them about Tory leadership contenders. I've written for them about Vladimir Putin, very much not a friend of the show, I have to say. I've written for them about J.R.R. Tolkien, which greatly annoyed you at the time because they didn't mention religion. They had Hadley Freeman recently. Brilliant article, actually.
坚决抵制群体思维，同时也招募了非常优秀的专栏作家，其中包括你自己。是的，我大约每两周为UnHerd写一次稿。我为他们写过关于保守党党魁候选人的文章，写过关于弗拉基米尔·普京的文章——我必须说，他绝对不是节目的朋友。我还写过关于J.R.R.托尔金的文章，这当时大大惹恼了你，因为他们没有提及宗教。他们最近还请了哈德利·弗里曼（Hadley Freeman）。那其实是一篇精彩的文章。
A great range of different voices, different perspectives, different political standpoints. And I think it's a wonderful website. They put what's kind of three or four kind of essays up every day. But you wrote an excellent essay for them after the sort of Trump capital riots, didn't you?
这里有各种各样不同的声音、不同的视角、不同的政治立场。我认为这是一个绝佳的网站。他们每天会发布大约三四篇优质文章。你在美国国会山骚乱之后为他们写过一篇出色的文章，对吧？
About the parallels between the fall of Rome, subject of today's podcast, and contemporary America, didn't you? What did you say? I said that, so it was about, was America going to fall as Rome had fallen? And I argued that because the founding fathers modelled the American Republic on the Roman Republic, they were shadowed by the threat both of autocracy and then a final
关于罗马帝国灭亡（也就是今天播客的主题）与当代美国之间的相似之处，对吧？你是怎么说的？我说的是，美国会像罗马那样灭亡吗？我辩称，由于建国先父们是以罗马共和国为蓝本塑造美国共和国的，他们同样笼罩在专制主义以及最终
collapse. And obviously, there was a lot of, you know, in the wake of the storming of the Capitol, there was a lot of anxiety about that. But I argued that the parallels were in a way so tendentious that americans need worry on that account but just because it happened to rome it's not necessarily going to happen to america so uh cheer up was my message yeah i think that's a reasonable i mean america is not an empire in any way thing like the same way i mean it's just an utterly different society isn't it so you i mean i think i think the only the only um the real way in which it kind of affects the discourse in america is that the very existence of the parallel leads people to think that um you know it's inevitably that it might actually happen and so in that sense it you know
崩溃的威胁阴影之下。显然，在国会山骚乱之后，人们对此产生了许多焦虑。但我辩称，这些相似之处在某种程度上过于牵强，美国人没必要为此担忧——仅仅因为这发生在罗马身上，并不一定会发生在美国身上。所以，我给出的信息是：振作起来吧。是的，我认为这很合理。我的意思是，美国在任何意义上都不是一个与罗马相同的帝国——它完全是一个截然不同的社会，对吧？所以，我认为它对美国话语体系产生的唯一真正影响在于，这种相似性的存在让人们觉得……
people continue to talk about it anyway do have a read of it uh see what you think um and and do check the rest of the magazine because i say say, it's full of great stuff. Now I should say, normally it is £1 a week, but as always with UnHerd, there is a special offer for Rest Is History listeners. So you get your first 10 weeks free, £10 off, basically. Amazing value.
（你知道的，这可能会不可避免地发生）。所以在某种程度上，人们无论如何都在谈论它。无论如何，去读一读吧，看看你的想法如何。一定要去看看这本杂志的其他内容，因为正如我所说，里面充满了精彩的内容。顺便说一句，通常每周是1英镑，但一如既往，UnHerd为《历史的余烬》听众提供了特别优惠。你的前10周免费，也就是直接省了10英镑。性价比极高。
Go to unherd.com slash rest. It's a really interesting publication that tackles these kinds of thorny stories. So there you go. From the horse's mouth. Goodbye. Welcome back to The Rest is History. So we are cantering through possible dates for the fall of the Roman Empire. Now, Tom, we got up to the end of the fourth century. So Rome has become Christian, or at least Christianity has become the state religion.
访问 unherd.com slash rest。这是一个真正探讨这类棘手故事的有趣出版物。所以，听听业内人士怎么说吧。再见。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在快马加鞭地梳理罗马帝国灭亡的各种可能日期。现在，汤姆，我们已经讲到了4世纪末。所以罗马已经基督教化，或者至少基督教已经成为了国教。
It is already, the empire is, I mean, this is a colossal subject and one that sort of bitterly divides academics to this day. So we don't need to get massively into it. But Rome is already having to face the challenge of mass migration from the east. In the year 410, Rome itself, the city, is sacked, isn't it? This colossal moment.
帝国已经——我的意思是，这是一个庞大的课题，至今仍在学术界引发激烈的争论。所以我们不需要深入探讨。但罗马已经不得不面对来自东方的移民潮的挑战。在公元410年，罗马城本身被洗劫了，对吧？这是一个极其震撼的时刻。
Can you tell us a bit about who does that and why? And why that's not the fall of Rome? Yeah, so the last time that Rome has been captured by barbarian enemies was with the Gauls back in the early 4th century BC. So a long, long time before. For a long time, Rome did not, you know, its walls have been left to crumble. Then in the 3rd century, it's a measure of how turbulent the times are that vast walls are built. And these are the walls that you can still see built by the Emperor Aurelian. But no one thinks that Rome, you know, there's a serious chance that Rome will be sacked.
你能跟我们讲讲是谁干的、为什么要这么做吗？以及为什么这并不意味着罗马的灭亡？是的，上一次罗马被蛮族敌人攻陷还要追溯到公元前4世纪初的高卢人。所以那是相当、相当久远以前的事了。在很长一段时间里，罗马的城墙都听任其荒废。然后在3世纪，为了应对动荡的局势，人们修建了宏伟的城墙。这些就是你今天依然能看到的、由奥勒良皇帝（Emperor Aurelian）修建的城墙。但当时没有人认为罗马真的面临被洗劫的严重危险。
But then in 378, there is an absolutely disastrous battle. The worst defeat that the Romans have suffered since the time of Hannibal, who had the great Carthaginian general. And essentially, this is a kind of immigration crisis, if you like. People called the Goths are trying to cross the Danube because in their rear, there are all kinds of kind of the distant hoofbeats of the Huns are starting to be heard. They want to cross over. The Romans agree, but it all kind of goes wrong. They set up camps. The camps aren't very good. And essentially the Goths who've crossed over, they attack the Romans. kind of goes wrong they set up camps the camps aren't very good then they um and essentially the goths who've crossed over uh they attack the romans the romans then attack them the romans lose an emperor is burnt to death in a shed um valence yes and it tears a massive great hole in the um
但随后在公元378年，发生了一场绝对灾难性的战役。这是罗马人自伟大的迦太基将军汉尼拔时代以来遭受的最惨重的失败。从某种程度上说，这基本上算是一场移民危机。被称为哥特人的人们正试图穿过多瑙河，因为在他们的后方，开始隐约听到匈人遥远的马蹄声。他们想要过河。罗马人同意了，但事情却开始变糟。他们建立了营地。营地建得并不好。那些过河的哥特人基本上对罗马人发动了进攻，事情开始变糟，他们建立了营地，营地并不好，接着他们……基本上，那些过河的哥特人袭击了罗马人，罗马人随后又反击他们，罗马人战败了，一个皇帝在一个棚子里被活活烧死，嗯，瓦伦斯，是的，这在……上撕开了一个巨大的口子
in the available manpower to to the to the. And essentially, you then start having bands of Goths roaming around the various provinces. And again, this isn't kind of something exceptional. Outsiders have repeatedly been kind of brought in within the fabric of the empire and settled and made Roman. The problem with the aftermath of Adrianople is that this hasn't happened. And therefore the Goths feel that they have a kind of license to start roaming around. And what happens in 410
可用的人力资源。基本上，你随后会看到一帮帮哥特人在各个行省四处游荡。同样，这并不是什么罕见的事。外来者曾多次被纳入帝国的体制内，安家落户并成为罗马人。阿德里安堡战役之后的麻烦在于，这一切并没有发生。因此，哥特人们觉得他们获得了一种四处游荡的“特许证”。而在公元410年发生的事情是
is that under their King Alaric, they fix on the richest prize of all, Rome. And they turn up and they discover that actually, you know, the capital of the empire has no clothes. It can be... So this is an extraordinary thing. It's people who don't know the story of the kind of the sort of the late
在他们的国王阿拉里克的带领下，他们盯上了最丰厚的战利品——罗马。他们兵临城下，却发现实际上，帝国的首都竟然“赤身裸体”，毫无防守。它可以被……所以这是一件极其离奇的事。对于那些不了解晚期古罗马时期、晚期罗马时期历史的人来说，这种大规模的——我的意思是，我不知道你该称其为游牧部族还是今天的学者会认为这个词带有太多偏见——但这种四处游荡的部落帮派竟然能够一路游荡到罗马城下，这看起来会完全令人匪夷所思。罗马是不设防的，或者说防守薄弱，我是这么认为的。他们竟然能轻而易举地闯入帝国首都，把一切都砸个稀巴烂。这听起来太不可思议了。我的意思是，这种事如果发生在
antique period, the sort of late Roman period, it will seem completely bewildering that this kind of massive, I mean, I don't know whether you'd call it a horde or whether academics today would consider that too loaded, but this sort of, this sort of roaming tribal kind of gang are able to basically roam all the way into Rome. Rome is undefended or weakly defended, shall I say. And they're able to just get into the imperial capital and smash everything up. That would seem extraordinary. I mean, the image of that happening in
任何现代社会都是不可想象的，对吧？嗯，我认为这恰恰反映出罗马和意大利在走向衰落的过程中，是多么的繁荣却又多么的浑然不觉。以至于人们根本、根本不会想到这种事可能会发生，因为正如我所说，意大利和罗马基本上……罗马已经有长达几个世纪、几个世纪、几个世纪没有遭到外国敌人的围攻了。正因如此，当它发生时，才会带来如此巨大的震撼。它以一种矛盾的方式影响着当时的基督教世界——因此圣哲罗姆
any modern society would be unthinkable, right? Well, I think it's the measure of how prosperous and unaware that it is in the process of declining and falling. Rome and Italy is. That people just, it doesn't cross people's mind that that that might happen um because as i say you know italy and rome have have basically been rome hasn't been sat by foreign enemies for centuries and centuries and centuries and so that's why when it happens it is such a shock it it affects it affects what is now a christian world in in contradictory ways so saint jerome who is he's in the holy land at the time, and he's brought
当时正在圣地，当消息传到他那里时，他将其视为一场绝对的灾难。他将罗马奉为世界的母亲。他简直不敢相信所发生的事情的消息。这等于是将罗马与基督教直接联系在了一起。因此，这也意味着对教堂的攻击。因为哥特人在这个时候仍然是异教徒，对吗？我想他们是阿里乌斯派。所以他们是一种不同类型的……
the news, and he regards it as an absolute catastrophe. He hails Rome as the mother of the world. He can't believe the news of what's happened. And that is to associate Rome with, basically with Christianity. But therefore, the attack on on, on, on the church as well. Because the Goths are still pagans at this point, are they? I think they, they're Aryans. So they're kind of different kind of,
一种不同类型的基督教。哲罗姆阐述了一种后来变得极具影响力的理解，即罗马的永恒是由上帝注定的。
um, a different kind of Christianity. Jerome articulates what will become a very, very influential understanding, which is that, um, Rome's eternity is ordained by God. That,
罗马的诞生是为了给耶稣的诞生以及接下来教会的传播提供完美的背景。因此，耶稣诞生于奥古斯都统治时期——当时到处都有道路、航运路线，每个人都在同一个统治者之下，因此基督教的信息得以传播。这是全能上帝的杰作。这随后融入了一种对保罗致帖撒罗尼迦人第二封信的非常独特的理解，他在信中写到了敌基督，而基督教学者们得出的结论是，正是罗马帝国在阻止敌基督的
that Rome had been brought into existence so as to provide the perfect um setting for jesus to be born and then for the church to spread so jesus is born in the reign of augustus um and they're all the roads and they're the shipping lanes and everybody's joined under the same ruler so therefore the christian message can spread. And this is the doing of the almighty. And this then feeds into a kind of very distinctive understanding of Paul's second letter to the Thessalonians, where he writes about the antichrist and Christian scholars come to the conclusion that it's the Roman empire that is stopping the antichrist from
到来。因此，只要罗马帝国存在，敌基督就不会到来。于是，罗马被写进了未来历史的织体中，启示录中的记载以及基督将再次降临的信念，深深烙印在人们的想象中。因此，罗马作为一座永恒之城的概念在某种意义上被基督教化了。罗马帝国作为将在基督徒认为迫在眉睫的伟大末日戏剧中扮演角色的实体的观念，是这一时期的重要特征。
coming. And that therefore, as long as the Roman empire exists, the Antichrist won't come. And so therefore, Rome gets written into the fabric of the history of the future, that the book of Revelation and the sense that Christ will come again is absolutely kind of writing in people's imaginations. So that's the sense of Rome as an eternal city in that sense is Christianized. The idea of the Roman Empire as something that will play a part in the great apocalyptic drama that Christians believe is looming is an important feature of this period.
但罗马的沦陷还有另一个非常深远且最终更具影响力的影响，那就是对来自北非的伟大主教奥古斯丁的影响。他回应了那些非基督徒参议员和非基督徒知识分子，他们看着罗马被洗劫的景象，说道：“之所以发生这一切，是因为我们背离了传统的生活方式和传统的诸神。我们抛弃了他们。因此，这表明我们应该回到老路上去。”而奥古斯丁则坚决表示：“绝非如此。这根本证明不了什么。”但他提出了一个激进的观点：罗马其实并没有那么重要，全人类、整个世界都已堕落，罗马也深陷其中。因此，整个世界都已堕落，罗马也深陷其中。从长远来看，帝国是屹立不倒还是轰然坍塌其实并不重要，
But the fall of Rome has another very, and ultimately more influential impact, which is on Augustine, the great bishop from North Africa. And he responds to non-Christian senators, non-Christian intellectuals who look at the spectacle of Rome being sacked. And they say, this has happened because we have turned our backs on the traditional way of doing things, the traditional gods. We have abandoned them. And therefore, this shows that we should go back to the old ways. And Augustine says, absolutely not. It doesn't prove this at all. But his argument is the radical one, that Rome is not particularly significant, that all of humanity, all the world is fallen. And therefore, Rome is implicated in that. And therefore, all the world is fallen, and therefore Rome is implicated in that. And therefore, in the long run, it doesn't really matter if the empire stands or falls,
因为真正重要的是教会。这样做所产生的结果是，在教会和帝国的概念之间树立了一种绝对关键的对比，这对于中世纪的欧洲，乃至我认为直到今天的我们，都具有极其深远的历史意义。好吧，但对大多数既不是奥古斯丁的狂热听众、也不是其忠实读者的普通人来说，罗马依然屹立不倒、税收仍在照常征收、引水渠在被修缮、军队依然存在、法律和秩序依然维持，这大概确实很重要吧？我的意思是，罗马沦陷与否，对人们来说其实至关重要，而且它在410年并没有彻底灭亡，所以……
because what matters is the church. And what that does is to set up an absolutely crucial contrast between the idea of the church and the empire, which will have very, very momentous implications for medieval Europe, and I think right the way into the present. Okay, but to most people who are not keen listeners to or readers of Augustine, presumably it does matter that Rome still stands, that the taxes are still being paid, aqueducts are being repaired, troops, that there's law and order. I mean, it actually genuinely matters to people that Rome falls or doesn't fall and it doesn't fall in 410 so the
哥特人在罗马进行了一场类似恶棍般的打砸抢烧，但这并不是帝国的终结，对吧？他们不知何故……尽管西罗马帝国在那个时候显然已经病入膏肓、苦苦挣扎。它依然持续了数十年，不是吗？是的，但从本质上讲，将西罗马帝国各地连接在一起的纽带开始被切断了。因此，大约在公元410年，不列颠似乎基本上挣脱了系缆。随着中央帝国维持武力垄断的能力不断减弱——这正是罗马帝国一直以来的核心所在，即维持武力垄断，是的——一旦这种集中控制开始滑坡，那么无论是罗马人还是蛮族军阀，从帝国的庞大身躯中割据一方的诱惑就会变得势不可挡。
goths have their sort of sort of hooligan rampage in rome but then that's that's that's not the end of the empire right that they somehow the although the western empire clearly at that point is ailing, struggling to cope. It still continues, doesn't it, for decades? Yes, but essentially, the sinews that have joined the various parts of the Western Empire together are starting to be cut. So around 410, Britain seems to essentially slip the moorings. And the more the ability of uh the central empire to to maintain a monopoly of force which is what the roman empire had always been about it's about maintaining monopoly of force yeah once that starts to slip a centralized control then the standing temptation for warlords whether they be roman or barbarian both, essentially to kind of carve off fiefdoms from the mass of the empire becomes overwhelming.
他们割据得越多，帝国走向内爆的进程就越不可逆转。实际上我想如果你是一个地方指挥官或者地方首领——“帮派头目”这个词可能不太准确，但你知道的，就是地方强人——总会有一个时刻，你会想：“我何必还要费劲把我的那份税收上交给上面的人呢？我的意思是，他们连军队都没有，我完全可以随心所欲，把钱留给自己。”然后，这大概就是一个……不能算短的一步，但却是不必多说的一步，最终这些人会说：“嗯，我可以当国王。我的意思是，我可以成为这个地方的国王。”这就是为什么，这就是为什么蛮族如此重要，因为事实上罗马精英阶层是非常非常文官化的、极其文官化。我的意思是，你知道的，他们整天只知道钻研维吉尔。他们肯定会去洗浴场所，然后……
And the more they do that, the more the empire, the process of implosion is set in trade. effectively i suppose if you're a local commander or a local a gang boss is the wrong word but you know the the local strongman there's a point at which you just think i'm not going to bother handing on my slice of the tax take to the guys above me i mean they don't have any troops i can just do what i like and keep it for myself and then and then presumably it's a um not a short step but it's an inevitable step that eventually these people will say well well i could, I could be king. I mean, I could be king of this place. Well, this is why, this is why the barbarians are so important because actually the, the Roman elite is very, very civilian, very civilian. I mean, you know, all they do is study Virgil. Surely they go to the baths and they...
他们会去澡堂之类的地方，但他们不是军事人才。是的。所以本质上，这一切都被外包给了蛮族，他们通常——你知道的，就像他们都说拉丁语一样，他们和任何人一样都是罗马人。但这有点像整个框架依赖于由中央皇帝维持的暴力垄断。当这种垄断不复存在时，你就只能开始迁就那些不可避免地开始接管权力的军人了。我们称这些人为蛮族，但正如我们所说，他们通常高度罗马化。于是你开始看到人们割据高卢的领土。接着是汪达尔人席卷西班牙，然后关键是他们渡过了非洲，而非洲正是
They go to the baths and things like that, but they're not, they're not military men. Yeah. And so essentially this has been franchised out to barbarians who are often, you know, just as they all speak Latin and they're as Roman as anyone. But it's a bit like framework depends on there being a monopoly of violence that's maintained by a central emperor. When that ceases, then you start having to accommodate the military men who inevitably are starting to take over. And we call these barbarians, but they're often very, very Romanized, as we said. So you start to get the people carving out chunks of gall. Then you get the vandals who sweep through spain and then crucially they cross into africa and africa is the great grain basket
为罗马提供粮食的巨大谷仓。一旦非洲失去，那就真的所剩无几了，罗马将陷入真正的麻烦，这就是这一历史日期的背景。是的，我料到我们会谈到这个。那么让我们快进到公元476年9月4日。罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯当时还是个孩子。我没记错吧？一个十几岁的少年？是的。一个小男孩？
that keeps rome fed and once that's gone then really there's nothing left uh and rome is in real trouble then and this is the background for this this date. Yeah, I thought we'd come to this. So let's get to the 4th of September, 476. So Romulus Augustulus has been, he is a boy. Am I right? A teenager? Yeah. A small boy?
我记不清了。具有讽刺意味的是，他的名字取自罗马的奠基人，而他的第二个名字我想意思是“小奥古斯都”。是这样吗？是的，这是一个带有侮辱性的昵称。我的意思是，他是罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯，所以这其实……所以我们可能会说“他叫这个名字真讽刺”，但这并不是巧合，这是刻意为之的，是一种嘲讽和贬低的方式。是的，他基本上是被一个叫奥多亚克的人废黜的——我不知道该怎么正确发音——他当时是东哥特人的首领。
I can't remember. He is named after, ironically, Rome's founder. And his second name means little Augustus, I think. Is that right? Yeah, it's an abusive nickname. I mean, it's romulus augustus so it's not really so so we say oh it's ironic he's called that but it's not it's not an accident it's it's deliberate it's a way of mocking and belittling yes yeah and he is basically deposed isn't he by a guy called odoaco i don't know how to pronounce it um who's the head of the Ostrogoths,
他基本上就把他赶出了……我的意思是，这到底是怎么运作的？所以罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯，是一个叫欧瑞斯特的人的儿子，欧瑞斯特是一个……算是来自巴尔干半岛的家伙。他是一个反疫苗者（注：此处为播客嘉宾的幽默现代梗或口误）。他被另一个同样来自巴尔干半岛的人——名叫尤利乌斯·尼波斯——任命为“军事统帅”，基本上就是军队最高统帅。而尤利乌斯·尼波斯，则是查理曼大帝之前最后一位在罗马加冕的皇帝。
who basically just kicks him out of the... I mean, how does it even work? So Romulus Augustus, he's the son of a guy called Orestes, who is a kind of a Djokovic guy. He's from the Balkans. He's an anti-vaxxer. And he's been appointed the magister militum, so basically the head of the army, by a guy called Julius Nepos, who also is from the Balkans. And Julius Nepos, he's the last emperor to be crowned in Rome until Charlemagne.
抱歉，这是一个非常非常无聊、老生常谈的问题。当你在此时成为皇帝时，这实际意味着什么？我的意思是，你会得到什么特殊的……你会得到一顶王冠吗？会得到一件长袍吗？是的。是的，你会得到长袍。然后你要做什么？你是在处理文书工作吗？你是在……是的。你手下还有公务员之类的吗？你拥有公务员，以及所有诸如此类的人。
Sorry, a really, really boring, banal question. When you become emperor at this point, what does that actually mean? I mean, do you get given a special... Do you get a crown? Do you get a robe? Yeah. Yeah, you get the robes. And what do you do? Are you doing the paperwork? Are you kind of... Yeah. And you have civil servants and stuff? You have civil servants, all that kind of stuff.
他们在此时只会不断给你带来坏消息。但到了这个时候，本质上你的统治范围已经萎缩到只剩下意大利和巴尔干半岛的一部分了。好吧。而且你极有可能在一场政变中被推翻，这基本上就是发生的事情：欧瑞斯特在背后捅了任命他为统帅的尤利乌斯·尼波斯一刀。尤利乌斯·尼波斯横渡亚得里亚海，回到他位于巴尔干半岛达尔马提亚的家乡避难。欧瑞斯特则让自己的儿子当上了皇帝。
Who are just constantly bringing you bad news at this point. But by this point, essentially, your rule has shrunk to Italy and a section of the Balkans. Okay. And you're very likely to be toppled in a coup, which is basically what happens, that Orestes stabs Julius Nepos, who's appointed him, in the back. Julius Nepos crosses the Adriatic to hang out in his native Dalmatia in the Balkans. Orestes makes his son emperor.
接着，欧瑞斯特被奥多亚克推翻——你刚才提到了东哥特人的国王——但从根本上说，他们之间其实没什么区别，大家都在为……你知道的，为这场盛宴争夺残羹冷炙。而奥多亚克只是觉得：这一切毫无意义，我的意思是，根本没有皇帝了，我索性自己当国王算了。于是他就这么做了。他把罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯打发到了……嗯……凯撒时代一位著名将军卢库卢斯的别墅里——就是那个把樱桃带回罗马的人，以及……
Orestes then gets toppled by a Durka, you've mentioned the king of the ostrogoths but basically there's very little to choose between them they're all kind of scrapping over the over the you know the the feast um and a durca just decides well this is pointless i mean you know there's no emperor i'm just going to make myself king and so that's what he does and he packs um uh romulus augustulus off to uh the villa of a famous general from the time of caesar called lucullus the guy who brought the cherry back to rome and um as far as we know yeah the cherry he brings the cherry back where the cherry bean uh pontus on the black sea okay wow that's a claim to fame poor old romulus augustulus kind of well poor i mean they yeah he seems to have had
据我们所知，是的，樱桃，他把樱桃带回了……那樱桃原本是在黑海海滨的本都。好吧，哇，这也是一种名垂青史的方式呢！可怜的罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯算是……说“可怜”吧，我的意思是，他们……是的，他似乎过得
quite a nice time the villa was clearly very swanky he's the richard he's the richard cromwell of romania he's the richard cromwell exactly exactly except we don't know how long he lived i mean we don't really know what happened to him but he is not actually the last so this is why saying that 476 is the date of the fall of the roman empire is wrong because um julius nepos is still very much on the scene. It's just that he's the other side of the Adriatic, the Balkans, and he lasts until 480 when he gets murdered. So if you wanted to say the end of, you know,
还挺不错的。那座别墅显然非常豪华。他简直就是罗马帝国的理查·克伦威尔，他就是理查·克伦威尔，完全没错——只不过我们不知道他活了多久。我的意思是，我们并不真的知道他后来怎么样了。但他实际上并不是最后一位西罗马皇帝，所以这就是为什么说公元476年是罗马帝国灭亡之日是错误的，因为尤利乌斯·尼波斯当时依然活跃在政治舞台上。只不过他在亚得里亚海的对岸、巴尔干半岛那边，一直坚持到公元480年被谋杀为止。所以，如果你想指出西罗马帝国的终结之日，
when does the Roman Empire in the West fall, it would be 480, I think. But, but, and this is crucial. Yes, yes, Dominic, yes. And the other but, the other but is that Odoica does not completely cast off Roman rule because he sends the insignia of the Empire of the West to Constantinople. And he basically rules as a kind of, you know, he gets his legitimacy from the fact that he's a friend and an ally of the emperor in constantinople so so in a way actually what's happened here is that odoica is in a way saying you don't need an emperor in the west anymore you you're that you're still the overlord the guy in constantinople but i'm your man in rome now and we don't need a
那应该是公元480年，我认为。但是——这也是至关重要的一点——是的，是的，多米尼克，是的。另一个“但是”是，奥多亚克并没有彻底抛弃罗马统治，因为他把西罗马帝国的帝国标志送到了君士坦丁堡。他基本上是以一种……你知道的，他的合法性来自于他是君士坦丁堡皇帝的朋友和盟友这一事实。所以从某种意义上说，这里发生的事情是：奥多亚克实际上是在对君士坦丁堡说：“你们在西方不再需要皇帝了，你们——那边的君士坦丁堡皇帝——依然是至高无上的宗主权拥有者，但我现在是你们在罗马的代理人，我们不再需要一个
separate emperor is that basically what's happening yeah that is basically what's happening. And it's a way it serves both sides well, because it gives prestige to these kings. So he's succeeded by Theoderic, who is a very Roman figure. And Italy in this, you know, under Odoca and Theoderic remains very, very Roman. Consuls continue to be elected. The Senate still sits in the Senate House. Chariot races happen in the Circus Maximus. Basically, the Romans have no idea that the Roman Empire in the West has fallen. And in lots of ways, it hasn't. The framework is still functioning. Quick question for you.
独立的皇帝了。”这基本上就是当时正在发生的事情吗？是的，这基本上就是正在发生的事情。这种方式对双方都很有利，因为它为这些国王增添了声望。因此，他之后由狄奥多里克继承，这是一个非常罗马化的政治人物。在奥多亚克和狄奥多里克的统治下，意大利依然保持着非常非常罗马化的面貌。执政官继续被选举产生。元老院依然在元老院大厦开会。马克西穆斯竞技场里依然举行着战车赛。基本上，罗马人根本不知道西罗马帝国已经灭亡了。而且在很多方面，它确实还没有灭亡。帝国的整个框架依然在正常运转。我有一个快速的问题要问你：
Has the focus moved from Rome to Ravenna at this point? Because it does move to Ravenna, doesn't it? Yes. Yeah. you has the focus moved from Rome to Ravenna at this point because it does move to Ravenna doesn't it yes yeah so so Ravenna had been the kind of the the place again where the where emperors within Italy are based because it's up north so close to the you know close to to where all the action is and you have a you it's open to the sea so that you can kind of slip away and you can have constant communications with Constantinople by sea right so sea. So everything is in a state of flux. But if I kind of pitched up Tom in Ravenna in 490 and I said to somebody, if I did some vox pops, has the Roman Empire fallen?
在这个时候，权力的重心是不是已经从罗马转移到拉文纳了？因为帝国的重心确实转移到拉文纳了，对吧？是的。是的。在这个时候，权力的重心是不是已经从罗马转移到拉文纳了？因为帝国的重心确实转移到拉文纳了，对吧？是的。拉文纳一直是意大利境内皇帝们的驻地，因为它位于北方，靠近……你知道的，靠近所有核心局势发生的地方。而且它面向大海，你可以随时抽身离开，并且可以通过海路与君士坦丁堡保持持续的沟通，对吧？所以一切都处于不断变动之中。但是，汤姆，如果我在公元490年突然出现在拉文纳，并且向某个人——如果我做个街头随机采访——询问：“罗马帝国灭亡了吗？”
What would people have said? I think they'd have said no. I think they wouldn't have understood the question because all around them, the evidence of Roman civilization and Roman cultural practices and political practices carries on it's just that there isn't an emperor ruling in italy but there is an emperor in constantinople so all the romans can feel that they're still the roman empire still exists meanwhile theodoric can feel that he is you know he's integrated into the roman system but he is a king and so he does this in the kind of classic way by issuing very roman style coins and medallions but showing himself with a
人们会怎么回答？我想他们会回答没有。我想他们根本无法理解这个问题，因为在他们周围，罗马文明的证据、罗马的文化实践和政治实践都在继续运转。只不过现在没有一个皇帝在意大利统治，但在君士坦丁堡有一个皇帝。因此，所有的罗马人仍然可以觉得自己生活在罗马帝国之中，罗马帝国依然存在。与此同时，狄奥多里克也可以觉得自己已经融入了罗马体系，但他是一位国王。所以他通过一种经典的方式来做到这一点：发行非常具有罗马风格的硬币和纪念章，但在上面刻着自己蓄着胡子的形象——而任何一个有自尊心的罗马人都是绝不会留胡子的。
moustache which no no self-respecting roman would ever wear no no of course not they'd look ridiculous and further afield the same thing is kind of happening. So in Gaul, where obviously the hold of Constantinople is very, very much weaker, even so, you're still getting the same kind of game being played. So you're getting, so Anastasius, one of the emperors in Constantinople in the 5th century, sends messages to Clovis,vis the frankish king saying um you know i'm appointing you a consul and this is great clovis can pretend to be a consul but that's completely meaningless to clovis right i mean does it mean it's not it's not it's not meaningless because it gives him a kind of stamp of prestige okay so it's still likewise you get kings kind of saying very freely um you know we we are subject to you. We acknowledge your supremacy, even though need.
不，当然不会，那样看起来太荒谬了。而在更远的地方，同样的事情也在发生。例如在高卢，君士坦丁堡的影响力明显要弱得多，即便如此，你依然能看到同样的政治游戏在上演。因此，5世纪君士坦丁堡的皇帝之一阿纳斯塔西乌斯，给法兰克国王克洛维发信息说：“我知道了，我任命你为执政官。”这太棒了，克洛维可以假装自己是个执政官。但这对于克洛维来说完全没有任何意义，对吧？我的意思是，这并不是说它完全没有意义，因为它为他提供了一种声望的印记。好吧！因此它依然发挥着作用。同样，你也会看到各国的国王非常随性地说：“我们效忠于您。我们承认您的最高权力”，尽管实际上根本不需要。
I mean, both sides know that this is bogus, but it suits the interests of both sides. Both are kind of flattered by it. However, by the beginning of the 6th century, Romans are starting to wake up to the fact that something has really quite seriously gone wrong. So you have one of them. He writes about how what the world needs is an armed Caesar before whose advance both land and sea will quake until at last with the renewed power of his war trumpet, he will serve to rouse the navies of Rome from their sleep. And that, of course, comes to fruition with Justinian, I know you're a big fan of, who does send an expedition to reconquer first Africa and then Italy. Well, let's just ask about that, Tom. You said reconquer. So we've moved on a generation
我的意思是，双方都心知肚明这只是一场虚伪的游戏，但它符合双方的利益。双方都因此感到受到了恭维。然而，到了6世纪初，罗马人开始清醒过来，意识到有些事情确实已经出了大问题。于是其中一位写道，这个世界需要的是一位全副武装的凯撒，在他的进军之下，陆地和海洋都将为之震颤，直到最后，伴随着他战争号角的新生力量，他将唤醒沉睡中的罗马海军。当然，这一切在查士丁尼的统治下成为了现实——我知道你是他的超级粉丝——他确实派遣了一支远征军，先后重新征服了非洲和意大利。好吧，让我们来谈谈这个，汤姆。你刚才用了“重新征服”这个词。所以我们已经比罗慕路斯·奥古斯苏卢斯被废黜、以及我们传统上视为西罗马帝国终结的时期，向前推进了一到两代人。
or two from the deposition of Romulus Augustus and the end of what we conventionally see as the end of the Western Empire. Is there a sense now in the East that the West has been lost? And that's basically because the kings are no longer responding to the messages. They're saying, you know, you can stuff your consulship. I'm my own boss now. Who cares what you think? Is that basically what's going on yeah they're barbarians i mean you know they are barbarians it's embarrassing you know it's we're
现在东方是否有一种感觉，觉得西方已经彻底失去了？这基本上是因为那些国王不再理会君士坦丁堡的信息了？他们会说：“去你的执政官吧，我现在是自己的老板了，谁在乎你的想法？”这基本上就是当时的情况吗？是的，他们是蛮族。我的意思是，他们就是蛮族，这太尴尬了。我们都很熟悉这种情况：当不同势力之间存在外交或条约关系时，最终其中一方会决定自己对此彻底失去兴趣。
kind of familiar with where you have diplomatic or you know um treaties between powers that eventually one decides it's just not interested in it yeah um and i think that that's basically what happens so justinian sends this this army which does kind of you know it's quite successful but the collateral damage is is actually the city of rome itself you know there are a series of very brutal sieges the aqueducts get cut so therefore the viability of rome as a major city is completely lost and it becomes very rapidly depopulated as a result both of of the collapse of infrastructure and of kind of forced movement of people.
我认为这基本上就是所发生的事情。因此，查士丁尼派出了这支军队，它确实取得了一定的成功，但其附带损伤却是罗马城本身。这里发生了一系列极其残酷的围城战，引水渠被切断，因此罗马作为一座大都市的生存能力彻底丧失了。由于基础设施的崩溃以及人口被强行迁徙，罗马人口迅速锐减。
So I think that if you want a date for when does the Roman Empire in the West really finish, I think it's then. And I think, ironically, the gravedigger of the Roman Empire in Italy is Justinian, the Roman Emperor, who's trying to bring Italy back into the embrace of the Roman Empire. Because the very act of the reconquest basically shatters the economy and the landscape of Italy. No more Senate, no more chariot races, no more consuls. That's when it ends.
所以我想，如果你想为西罗马帝国的真正终结找一个日期的话，我认为就是这个时候。具有讽刺意味的是，意大利罗马帝国的掘墓人正是查士丁尼——这位试图将意大利重新拥抱回罗马帝国的罗马皇帝。因为这场重新征服的行动本身，彻底粉碎了意大利的经济和地貌。不再有元老院，不再有战车赛，不再有执政官。一切都在这里迎来了终结。
But just to wind this story up, because we'll obviously have to take a break now and do the rest in subsequent episodes, so often the story of this podcast, the Roman Empire has had two capitals for a long time. So Constantinople. Meanwhile, Constantinople still think everybody there thinks of themselves as Romans. To them, the Roman Empire is absolutely going strong. They are the guardians of it. They have chariot racing, you know, with the famous kind of blues and the greens that riot. And they have triumphs.
不过，为了给这个故事做个收尾——因为我们显然必须在这里休息一下，并在接下来的节目中继续探讨——正如本播客经常讲述的那样，罗马帝国其实长期拥有两个首都。一个是君士坦丁堡。与此同时，君士坦丁堡的人们依然认为自己是罗马人。对他们来说，罗马帝国绝对正处于鼎盛时期。他们是帝国的守护者。他们那里有战车赛，有那些经常爆发暴乱的著名的“蓝党”和“绿党”。他们还有凯旋式。
So Justinian celebrates a triumph, just as Romans have done in the streets of roman yeah so so it very much carries on so this is and and this is absolutely we call this if i look up justinian online if i google him he will be described probably more often than not as a byzantine emperor but he is absolutely a roman emperor. He's a Latin speaker. Okay. He speaks Latin. Okay. Very good.
所以查士丁尼庆祝凯旋式的方式，就跟罗马人在罗马街道上做过的一模一样。所以这一切都在延续。这就是……我们称之为——如果我在网上搜索查士丁尼，如果我谷歌他，他被描述为“拜占庭皇帝”的频率可能会更高，但他绝对是一个罗马皇帝。他是一个拉丁语使用者。好吧。他说拉丁语。好吧，非常好。
Perfect. So we have got to the mid-6th century. The Roman Empire, contrary to what you often read, has absolutely not fallen. Britain is no longer part of it, or Britannia, I should say. Gaul is no longer part of the Roman Empire. And oddly, Italy and basically Rome are soon to be detached from the Roman Empire base. They're kind of semi-detached at this point,
太完美了。所以我们已经来到了公元6世纪中期。与你经常读到的相反，罗马帝国绝对没有灭亡。不列颠——或者我应该说不列颠尼亚——不再是它的一部分了。高卢也不再是罗马帝国的一部分。奇怪的是，意大利和基本上罗马城也很快将从罗马帝国的根据地中剥离出来。在这个时候，它们算是处于半脱离状态，
aren't they? Mid-6th century. I mean, just in this tricep. Well, no, Rome has now been brought back into the Roman Empire, but it's in a bad way. It's going to fall out again pretty soon, isn't it? A few centuries. It's there for a few centuries more. We will return next time with what happens to the eastern roman empire and also the afterlife of rome because tom i think you believe that rome doesn't die uh with well it does die but there are attempts to bring it back to life so it's it kind of takes on a vampiric form it's undead rome undead rome zombie romans so return to us next
对吧？公元6世纪中期。我的意思是，就在这个节点。好吧，不，罗马现在已经被重新纳入罗马帝国，但它的境况非常糟糕。不久之后它又会再次脱离控制，不是吗？再过几个世纪。它还将存在好几个世纪。我们将在下期节目中回归，探讨东罗马帝国的命运，以及罗马的来世。因为汤姆，我想你坚信罗马并没有随之消亡——嗯，它确实消亡了，但有许多试图让它复活的尝试，所以它以一种吸血鬼般的形式延续了下来，这就是“不死的罗马”，不死的罗马，僵尸罗马！所以请在下期节目中
time for zombie Romans. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
继续收听我们关于僵尸罗马的讨论。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论以及各种八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐产业的幕后运作，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场活动门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。